bonjour nicolas dupont aignan jour
monsieur alors nous sommes ensemble
pendant 20 minutes pour une interview
politique en partenariat avec la presse
quotidienne régionale qui représentait
aujourd'hui par florent buisson
journalistes à la république du centre
basé à la rédaction d'orléans bon en
feront bon joueur bonjour monsieur
nicolas dupont aignan on commence cet
entretien par évoquer forcément la coop
26 qui s'est ouverte ce week-end à
glasgow est ce que vous êtes confiant
dans la volonté de dirigeants de des
pays du monde entier et bien d'augmenter
leurs efforts pour lutter contre le
réchauffement climatique dans les
paroles de certainement le problème
c'est qu'on est très loin du respect des
précédents objectifs et on en ajoute un
autre et le problème de fond vous le
connaissez c'est la chine qui était très
mal représentés à cette coop et qui
finalement en fait et le passager
clandestin du monde donc je trouve qu'il
ya beaucoup de d'erreur beaucoup
d'approximations beaucoup de
culpabilisation des français alors que
nous sommes le pays qui polluent le
moins au monde par habitant grands pays
industrialisés vous savez que nous
sommes dans le peloton de tête 6e et l
ocde l'allemagne est 13e les états unis
30e et la chine n'en parlons pas donc ce
que j'aimerais c'est que on sable on
aborde les vrais enjeux et quel est le
vrai enjeu c'est de limiter nos
importations de produire français
puisque nous avons un modèle énergétique
grâce au nucléaire qui nous permet
d'avoir une production sans gaz à effet
de serre est plutôt que de culpabiliser
en permanence les français les
automobilistes leur faire croire que
c'est de leur faute on ferait mieux de
fermer les centrales bon polonaise et et
allemandes et et de faire pression sur
la chine en si je devais résumer à
chaque fois qu'on achète un produit
allemand ou un produit chinois ou
contribuer à effet de serre est temps
qu'on dira pas ça aux français ont leur
mentir à ses salariés mais évidemment
plus large que celui de la france se
fait aussi sur le sur le terrain de
l'union européenne est ce que l'union
européenne et la france doivent agir de
deux concerts gens me dire pour pour
lutter bien sûr être moteur danse est
lui bien sûr mais en fait l'union
européenne fait tout le contraire quand
l'union européenne signent un accord
avec le ceta avec le canada qui extrait
des schistes bitumineux quand l'union
européenne prévoit un accord
d'investissement majeur avec la chine
quand l'union européenne signent
l'accord avec le mercosur
donc il ya une sorte de schizophrénie
c'est à dire d'un côté tout le monde il
faut faut lutter on passe même de 2
degrés à 1,5 formidable on est sur une
tendance à 3 donc on est en plein délire
et en même temps nous explique en france
les aient des feux on va interdire aux
français d'accéder en voiture dans les
métropoles alors que c'est pas ça qui
polluent c'est rien par rapport aux
vrais enjeux donc moi j'aimerais juste
qu'on aille sur les vrais enjeux au
niveau international c'est à dire faire
effet de levier j'ai écrit un rapport
sur la pollution des océans qui est un
truc dramatique avec le sait en
plastique on voit que les pays d'asie ne
respecte aucune règle donc ici on ne se
sert pas du commerce mondial pour faire
effet de levier en dix ans soit une taxe
carbone aux portes de l'europe soient la
rupture des accords commerciaux tant
qu'il n'y a pas un effort côté chinois
pour vraiment lutter contre les gaz à
effet de serre on va à la fois emmerder
les français pardonnez moi et avoir la
planète qui saute c'est ça que
j'aimerais en revanche en france il ya
des choses qu'on peut faire de mieux
c'est l'économie circulaire c'est à dire
recycler davantage c'est le thermique je
propose dans mon projet présidentiel que
les aides aux éoliennes qui sont
totalement inutiles partent vers
l'isolation des foyers parce que au
rythme de ma prime rénove on y sera dans
un siècle donc le plan du gouvernement
qui selon vous met pas assez ambitieux
il est totalement dérisoire c'est mieux
qu'avant il a rajouté en 2022 3
milliards ce qui est bien mais si vous
voulez je regardais il ya 800 mille
logements à peu près rénové mais que en
général c'est un changement de chaudière
ou des fenêtres mais c'est pas du tout
une isolation c'est une moyenne de 5000
euros rendez compte et et ça fait huit
cent mille logements il ya 4,8 millions
de passerelles thermique donc il faut
absolument mettre le paquet c'est dans
mon projet présidentiel le paquet sur
l'isolation thermique parce que c'est
bon pour monet est bon pour
l'environnement on arrivera à lutter
contre la pollution que si ça permet
aussi de faire des économies de pouvoir
d'achat il faut lier les deux autres
sujets international nicolas dupont
aignan les tensions entre la france et
la grande bretagne autour des licences
des pêcheurs français dans la manche
est-ce qu emmanuel macron a eu raison
hier soir de temporiser et de reporter
les sanctions française contre les
pêcheurs britannique c'est une histoire
de fou enfin il faut qu'on arrive à un
accord avec la grande bretagne parce que
il s'agit de licence on devrait quand
même entre deux grands pays adultes
trouver un accord il ya urgence le voilà
je pense qu'il ya tellement de sujets
tellement dramatique et dans le monde si
on devrait quand même se mettent autour
d'une table et trouver un accord je vois
pas pour contrôler ce que c'est pas la
plus mauvaise des publicités pour les
souverainistes dont vous faites parti
qui prône une sortie de l'union
européenne ce type de désaccord qui
pénalise durablement le les pêcheurs
français d'abord je prône pas une sortie
l'union européenne je propose une je
prône une refonte complète des traités
au contraire on voit aujourd'hui avec le
break site que johnson et fort qu
johnson nous a torpillé le contrat des
sous-marins vous avez sans que le
royaume-uni est en bas le royaume uni
est en marche le royaume il y en a en
france est exactement pareil même pire
donc il ya des pénuries partout et
simplement il ya un pays qui est libre
et il ya un un emmanuel macron qui a
enchaîné dépendants et les éléments
français pareil il est enchaîné
d'ailleurs l'allemagne le lâchent en
permanence on l'a vu sur la sphère des
sous marins ou au moment où johnson nous
sabordait madame merkel signé un accord
avant la question débouche enfin sur la
question des fétiches feriez si vous
étiez à m très simple aux manettes je ne
m'occupe je ne travaillerai plus et
l'union européenne sur la pêche je
travaillerai directement et jazz en
bretagne on aurait un accord avec un
bras de fer je défendrai les intérêts de
la france pas comme a fait emmanuel
macron qui fait semblant pas ce que vous
allez voir qu'il a retiré ses sanctions
et qui va se coucher comme d'habitude
donc ça c'est détriment des pêcheurs
français mais malheureusement parce
qu'il ya d'un côté un homme qui défend
ses intérêts nationaux et de l'autre un
homme qui ne les défend pas donc mais
cette affaire il faut un accord global
avec la grande bretagne sur tous les
sujets et ça passe par une négociation
de liberté sans passer par l'union
européenne c'est la seule solution en
revanche moi je suis pour des programmes
coopération aubaine comme on à airbus
ariane parce que si on veut faire face à
la chine et aux états unis oui il faut
de l'europe mais de l'europe par
coopération par projet donc je ne suis
pas pour un freak site je suis pour une
renégociation
on retrouve nos frontières notre budget
non loi et puis en revanche osasuna ont
fini avec cette union européenne qui
nous tue à petit feu en revanche il faut
des coopérations européennes est
d'ailleurs la grande bretagne en aplats
et d'ailleurs si vous regardez ce qui
s'est passé qu'est ce qui s'est passé
l'allemagne a cédé la france parce que
pourquoi pour vendre leurs produits en
novembre- tan je vous rappelle qu'on a
quand même un excédent but commercial
avec la grande bretagne compte pas
l'oublier tant nicolas dupont aignan a
évoqué les questions de sécurité
qu'est-ce que vous avez ce drame oui
voilà on va parler notamment des
agressions de policiers et de tableaux
des primes qui encouragés et bien au
meurtre de policiers également au viol
deux policières c'est un enseignement de
ce week-end qu'est ce que vous proposez
dans mais surtout fait part de deux
policiers ce parachutiste qui hier soir
a été lynché
ce parachutiste lynché dans une rue de
france à la sortie d'un restaurant enfin
je sais pas si vous voyez où on en est
dans notre pays
c'est partout la violence pourquoi parce
que ça fait des années
et s'est accentuée par monsieur dupont
moretti et par ce gouvernement mais ça
que vous avez encore ce matin sur
twitter je crois sur une autre vidéo
d'un autre fait divers à vaulx en velin
c'est d'ailleurs dont on ne sait pas en
tout cas vous trouvez normal qu'un
parachutiste va au dîner au restaurant
se fait lyncher battu à mort moi je
parle d'un autre ferry vers il y en a
partout
concrètement ce que j'ai fait je suis
toujours des peines de prison
systématique la fin des remises de peine
pour les récidivistes des peines
planchers des condamnations pour les
trafics de drogue au maximum de leur
peine alors que la plupart des prononcer
sous de moitié la construction de 40000
places de prison quand j'ai proposé cela
en 2017 tout le monde m'a ri au nez le
bagne aux kerguelen pour les islamistes
avi si on ne rétablit pas la peine de
mort y est il hors du coup mais l'édile
a été condamné à cinq ans de prison
comme c'est la plupart du cac et à la
fin ils font deux ans eh ben ils font 20
ans de prison comme aux états unis je
veux dire tant que vous n'aurez pas une
peine dissuasive faut pas s'attendre à
ce qu'ils arrêtent puisqu'ils gagnent
tellement d'argent tellement d'argent je
vous donne un exemple très précis dans
ma circonscription 1 points de deal
qu'on connaît tous les policiers y
travaille pendant un an ils font une
enquête izon un résultat la moitié des
mines les mineurs sont relâchés
immédiatement immédiatement et les
majeures il y en a deux qui s'échappe
sont toujours pas rattrapé le procès
aura lieu dans six mois ou dans un an le
point dit il est toujours là donc tant
qu'il n'y aura pas de sanction tant que
les délinquants savent que la justice
est faible donc monsieur dupont moretti
justice est trop laxiste aujourd'hui
enfin les pas trop laxistes elle est
d'une faiblesse insigne et c'est pas
seulement la faute des magistrats
attention les magistrats appliquent les
lois la plupart du temps c'est la faute
des lois qui sont beaucoup trop laxiste
pour une raison très simple c'est comme
n'a pas de places de prison qu'est ce
qu'on fait tous les gouvernements ils
ont fait preuve de fermeté en paroles et
en actes on a voté ici au sénat à
l'assemblée des textes qui permettent
des peines alternatives pour les courtes
peines aux pays bas aux pays bas une
expérience a été mise en place
dès le premier délit une peine de prison
vraiment
aujourd'hui le résultat est
extraordinaire ils ont diminué le nombre
de prisonniers pourquoi parce que la
sanction vient dès le début et casse les
parcours qui monte en puissance des
délinquants donc il faut revoir toute
politique pénale et c'est pourquoi
j'avais vu la saison c'est la prison là
mais la prison n'est pas la suisse mais
non celle inverse c'est cette fausse
idée qu'on a en france eux et que les
pays anglo saxons ont montré que c'était
faux c'est la théorie du carreau cassé à
new york a permis de rétablir le calme à
new york c'est la théorie britannique
c'est la théorie des pays bas mais
attention pas n'importe quelle prison
j'ai pas je vous dis pas de mettre un
primo délinquant de 16 ans dans la même
prison qu'aujourd'hui c'est pourquoi
j'avais proposé les casernes
désaffectées
en faire des centres de détention de
primo délinquants c'est pourquoi en
gradation dans l'eau mais bien
évidemment et quelque chose avec des
psychologues avec une éducation il
s'agit pas de tomber dans un tout
répressif il s'agit qu'à chaque délit y
ait une peine appliquée vous savez
combien de peine pas appliquée en france
actuellement cent mille nos policiers
n'en peuvent plus les mères n'en peuvent
plus les maires j'ai encore eu un mère
au téléphone ya pas longtemps quelqu'un
lui court lui fonce dessus en voiture
dans la cour de sa ferme l' affaire est
classée
donc quand on en est là dans un pays
faut pas s'étonner de voir ce qui se
passait tous les délinquants le savent
ils sont pas idiots ils le savent on va
maintenant passer à la crise sanitaire
puisque nicolas dupont aignan en tant
que député de l'essonne vous proposer
une commission d' enquête sur les effets
indésirables des vaccins est ce que vous
considérez qu'on nous cache des choses
sur ces effets indésirables on va quand
même regarder les chiffres donnés par l'
agence nationale de sécurité du
médicament selon lesquelles et bien 0 1%
des personnes vaccinées en france ont eu
des effets indésirables avec le vaccin
contrôle coville est en majorité des
effets non graves écoutez ce que je
demande c'est juste la transparence il
ya des statistiques eudravigilance union
européenne que vous connaissez il ya des
statistiques vérité pas d'essence pas
envie de vérité mais je vais venir de
transparence de vérité il ya des effets
indésirables plus ou moins je pense que
ça rassurerait tout le monde d'avoir une
interprétation une analyse comme ça se
fait dans tous les pays développés y a
qu'en france où c'est l'omerta voilà ce
que je demande je demande surtout je
demande surtout qu'on rétablisse la
gratuité des tests parce que vous savez
que l'épidémie repas on en voit une
légère remontée mais qui peut le taux de
reproduction est supérieur à 1 j'ai
toujours été un des plus prudents sur le
co vide on s'est moqué de moi souvenez
vous en février 2020 parce que je
demandais le masque le port du masque
dans les lieux fermés à l'époque le
ministre me critiquer pour cela j'ai été
le premier à demander des tests j'ai été
le premier à demander la suspension des
vols venant de chine donc je suis
quelqu'un de prudent et je regrette ce
paiement des tests aujourd'hui qui fait
que beaucoup de gens de ce test plus je
regrette le pass sanitaires et je me
réjouis qu'au sénat y ait des sénateurs
courageux qui luttent contre le pass and
i ter qui est une fausse protection une
fausse protection car vous pouvez être
vaccinés et porter le virus je demande
qu'on rende rétablisse les tests
gratuits et je demande qu'on supprime le
pass annie taire parce que ça induit une
fausse protection et je demande surtout
baisse
sur les lits d'hôpitaux quand j'aimerais
qu'on parle des lits d'hôpitaux quand
même sur le à ce que
j'aime parce que vous avez signé par dit
que le vaccin on peut être vaccinés et à
transmettre leurs idées études qui
montrent que le nu la charge virale du
virus s'est par ailleurs légèrement mais
il ya des études qui montrent parents
parlent de 15 en un an c'est
complètement faux ces douze fois moins
15 fois moi totalement faux reprenez
toutes les études aujourd'hui évier
américaine cdc europe israël aujourd'hui
on se sait c'est une certitude que le
vaccin peut protéger de forme grave
la personne et c'est tant mieux et c'est
pourquoi j'ai toujours demandé
la vaccination des fragiles et des
personnes âgées mais qu'en revanche la
variation n'empêche pas la transmission
est pire que des gens là est réduit non
non elle
a réduit un petit peu mais vous pouvez
avoir une charge virale transmise par
les vacciner ce qui explique et les
sénateurs l'ont très bien dit pendant le
débat au sénat comme je les dis à
l'assemblée et monsieur rufin aussi et
d'autres de l'opposition des
républicains le pass sanitaire est une
hypocrisie e nuit en erreur nos
concitoyens qui relâche les gestes
barrière
donc moi je demande juste qu'à la veille
de l'hiver vu la situation de l'hôpital
je voudrais qu'on revienne sur l'hôpital
quand vous pensez que le ministre a mis
en danger la vie d'autrui en suspendant
20000 non vaccinés soignants qui pouvait
faire des tests il ya des autotests d'où
l'émoi j'ai proposé quelque chose parce
que je suis prudent j'ai proposé que les
soignants non vaccinés phase des tests
tous les trois jours un test pas la mort
donc je demande qu'on remette les 20000
soignants suspendu dans hôpital qui est
aujourd'hui est en faillite et
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas que le coc vide
il ya des opérations cancéreuses ou de
tumeurs cancéreuses qui sont repoussés
parce que les blocs opératoires sont
fermés c'est le plus grand scandale
sanitaire donc vous soutenez par exemple
aussi dans le même sujet ces
départements qui refuse de verser le rsa
aux
salariés de 2,2 lassant je les rejette
rossa scandaleux je trouve ça scandaleux
qu'on fasse des différences comme ça
ja devant de vue du gouvernement et ses
appartements qu'ils ont c'est scandaleux
c'est une honte abominable non seulement
ces soignants ont été au front ils ont
soigné au moment de l'épidémie alors
qu'ils n'avaient pas de blouse pas de
masque on les jette comme des chiens on
en a besoin les blocs opératoires sont
fermées parce que monsieur vers en
suspens des soignants non vaccinés qui
pourrait se faire tester ces
départements mais il faut que ces
désistements bien évidemment il faut
surtout qu'ils soient réintégrés par
l'hôpital pour sauver des malades il n'y
a pas que le coc vide il ya je voyais
encore il ya une très belle enquête dans
le figaro ce matin qu'ils disent que je
disais il ya deux mois quand même ce qui
est quand même incroyable c'est que on
le disait il ya deux mois on est une
poignée de sénateurs une poignée de
députés et on a alerté et le ministre
par idéologie par sectarisme
volontairement saborder l'hôpital mais
je sais pas si vous réalisez ce qui se
passe moi je le dis et olivier ferrand
devrait démissionner je demande sa
démission
ce ministre est dangereux pour les
français dangereux je pèse mes mots il
faut réintégrer les soignants il faut
faire des tests et des tests c'est pas
compliqué
nicolas dupont aignan a parlé de
l'élection présidentielle c'est votre
troisième candidature et vous faites
actuellement au tour de france pour
récolter les parrainer où il appelle il
faut je la fais appel aux maires il faut
voilà 500 parrainages d'élus c'est pas
facile à la présidentielle où vous en
êtes sûr fait parrainages j'avance
heureusement j'ai un réseau très fidèle
de merde qui me suit depuis des années
j'ai été maire 22 ans
c'est la plus belle fonction souvent je
la regrette combien sont ils aujourd'hui
à vous soutenir à b cette fabrication
j'en ai jamais dit pourquoi pourquoi
parce que ça sert à rien cette course de
petits chevaux ce que je dit juste c'est
qu'il me manque c'est que j'appelle les
maires à me permette pouvoir m'exprimer
car ça dépend d'eux
on a bien avancé mais il moment quand
même dire la moitié à
avancer heureusement plus de la moitié
mais il en manque je suis pas sûr d
avoir je vais très franc vous êtes
aujourd'hui de me rendre c'est très
difficile et j'appelle les maires à
m'aider à pouvoir m'exprimer librement
car je pense est un des rares à
m'exprimer en fonction de mes
convictions on peut ne pas être d'accord
avec moi mais j'ai toujours été sincère
dans mon combat et pourquoi c'est
difficile monsieur du point
nature plantes qui n'ont franchement on
porte les mêmes idées en a tellement
s'il n'en fait écho à zemmour nom pareil
par exemple franchement non
ce qui est dur c'est que je trouve qu'il
ya de moins en moins de maires qui
paraît il ya un sentiment d'écoeurement
des mères que je comprends
parce que la loi notre les
intercommunalités ce sentiment d'être
inutile les mères n'en peuvent plus des
règles je demande l'abrogation de la loi
nôtre je demande qu'on réhabilite la
commune qu'ont leurs rudes lui redonne
de la liberté ils ont le sentiment
d'être étouffée par des
intercommunalités immense
bureaucratiques qui les empêchent d'agir
et les maires sont un peu écoeuré et dix
bombes à peu près comme les français
ras-le-bol et je leur dis au contraire
permettait que candidat qui a été maire
puisse s'exprimer voilà donc je fais
appel aux maires mais il ya heureusement
ça avance nicolas dupont aignan comment
vous expliquer le phénomène eric zemmour
qui est aux portes du second tour si on
regarde les sondages et qui reprend vos
thèses souverainistes est ce que
finalement il n'est pas en train de
réussir ce que vous
vous n'avez pas réussi à faire c'est à
dire doubler marine le pen alors d'abord
de choses eric zemmour ne dit pas du
tout la même chose que moi en ce moment
je n'ai jamais été aussi loin dans un
discours
comme cela et je ne partage pas
certaines 206 xs compenser de sang et je
le dis je le dis comme je le pense
j'aime bien eric zemmour sur certains
points nous partageons l'amour de la
france et la souveraineté de la france
mais en revanche est gaulliste pour moi
et si je suis gaulliste de 2,2 après aux
jeunes par des brevets soi-même de
gaullisme même disons que j'ai ça dans
le coeur pour moi l'indépendance de la
france va obligatoirement avec le
rassemblement des français ça j'en suis
convaincu c'est à dire que je ne connais
que deux catégories de français ceux qui
font leurs devoirs et ce qu'ils ne font
pas mais pour moi l'origine le prénom
tout ça c'est cette absurde ça divise
les gens premier point deuxième point je
crois que cyril zemmoura dans des
sondages qui ne représente que ceux qui
sont certains d'aller voter c'est parce
qu'elle a eu une
promotion médiatique ahurissante et et
tant mieux pour lui mais j'aimerais et
je vous remercie de m'inviter j'aimerais
qu'il y ait un rééquilibrage parce que
zemmour le matin et l'après midi très
bien libre à lui et moi je ne suis pas
jaloux mais quand même j'aimerais
légalité et puis les français jugeront
car n'oubliez pas que ces sondages sont
faits sur ceux certains d'aller voter
c'est à dire la moitié des français à la
présidentielle il ya 20 millions
d'électeurs de plus et il va y avoir un
vrai débat solution contre solution je
suis un homme de terrain pouvoir d'achat
sécurité
services publics dans nos campagnes
économie mon livre où va le pognon
comment est ce qu'on prend l'argent
comment on le redistribue parce que
c'est très bien les grandes déclarations
c'est très bien les polémiques mais
après on fait quoi six mois jaspal
ronzitti dit qu'ils attendaient la suite
attendront marine le pen excusez moi je
suis
regardé les électeurs qui si vous
regardez le panel des électeurs qui en
général votent pour moi il y en a
beaucoup du centre il ya beaucoup de
personnes qui ne n'appartiennent à aucun
camp politique
vous savez eric zemmour est plus un
problème pour marine le pen que pour moi
je suis convaincu que je porterai une
voix de liberté on parlait du pass
sanitaire eric zemmour l'acceptent je
porterai une voix de liberté de
démocratie je veux créer le référendum
d'initiative citoyenne je veux même
mettre en place au référendum
révocatoire
je veux qu'on rende le pouvoir aux
français je pense que on ne règlera les
problèmes
que si on change le rapport au pouvoir
des dirigeants c'est à dire que vous
pouvez lire un autre président si
gouverne comme emmanuel macron d'en haut
et si les français ne veulent pas
changer c'est à dire radicalement changé
de politique on n'y arrivera pas donc je
porterai un projet gaulliste démocratie
rassemblement indépendance nationale et
puis on verra les sens et jugeront et ce
sont les mots de la fin merci beaucoup
merci à nicolas dupont aignan d'avoir
été notre invité
[Musique]